it was business as usual Monday for the
Ukrainian president but he did mention
on his telegram page that he was briefed
on the struggle against traders in
Ukraine
the country's Security Service
spokesperson says on the eve of a visit
to the mikolaiif region a Russian
informant was trying to collect
Intelligence on the president
these images are from Vladimir
zielinski's visit to make a lie of last
month but it's not clear if this was the
trip the alleged Russian operative was
using to learn the locations times and
routes the president would be traveling
officials shared this obscured image of
the woman in question but did not
release her name
they were tipped off about her and
launched additional security measures
including counter surveillance plots
against zelenski are not new the
secretary of the National Security
defense Council told global news last
year that on four occasions he had to
tell the president about possible
assassination attempts
his reaction is a night oh again he says
but they have to tell him
it's not known how many more attempts
there have been since that interview but
the president travels a lot more now and
is more visible compared to the early
days of Russia's full invasion
what hasn't changed is the toll the war
is taking on families Ukrainian
officials say one woman died when Russia
hit this building in the Hassan region
early Monday
Ukraine as a part of its
counter-offensive is fighting to reclaim
recently lost territory and
long-occupied regions like Crimea on
Sunday it hit two bridges in that area
including the Chona Road Bridge
Rob Hubert is a military strategist
because you have this this overlap
between the political military means I
see this particular element of the war
intensifying this is where there's going
to be some very increasing fighting
because the stakes are so important for
both sides with a push to reclaim
territory and the foiled assassination
attempt the updating of the motherland
statue in Kiev with the Ukrainian
Trident serves as a larger than life
reminder of the need for defense but
also victory
Crystal commencing Global News London